non-comedogenic means that something  won't clog your pores ideally for a  brand to claim this they would have  tested it on a bunch of people's faces  and looked for clogged pores but this  rarely ever happened sometimes they'll  have tested it on people's backs this  isn't too bad but back skin isn't face  skin but most of the time the brand  would have just made it with ingredients  that didn't clog pores in other people's  tests whether that was on rabbit ears or  people's backs or actual face skin now  the problem with this is sometimes an  ingredient can clog pores on its own but  one clogged pores were mixed and vice  versa so i just ignored that label claim  altogether i think the best way is just  to look at reviews of other people who  have used it and see if it broke them  out and just test it on your own skin